and now
a former winner
the man who's known for his storied
television career
and for the purposes of keeping it clean
he's not known for anything else
our host for this evening bob saget bob
thank you hawk
good evening everybody uh this is really
inspiring it is a pleasure for me to be
asked to host the 40th anniversary
celebration of the student academy
awards i also had the pleasure of
hosting the 30th anniversary celebration
of the student academy awards and since
then i am 10 years older and
three relationships wiser
well two of them were wiser one of them
i'd rather not talk about
unless you have like seven minutes um
i'd like to tell the aristocrats joke
now if i could
no sir
thank you thank you so much
some of you may have been surprised to
see me show up in the film you just saw
about student academy award winners and
one reason is i don't usually show up on
film because i am the undead
rich miller told me to take that joke
out and i did not listen to him he said
i just i don't get it
i met rich when i was 21 years old here
and uh he never touched me
while
there is surveillance footage but um
it was on 16.
while it's been a while since i was here
as a student winner i've always been
very proud very very proud of that
accomplishment back then these awards
were known as the student film awards
and i won't say how long ago i won it
1978 but i'm not going to say
how long ago it was 1978.
there's a photo that's a photo of me
that they're showing now that's really
upsetting to me that that was in that
film i mean that's disturbing those are
welding glasses i believe and i i had a
comb over i believe at 15 my mother gave
me a comb over because she had one and
thought i should have one also
and that uh that's a piece of wood um
and that is what i looked like and this
is a thing that i wasn't even going to
share but i want to share hawk's father
howard w koch when when all of you award
winners are here and you're getting
taken around town and and i know you're
taking you to strip clubs and buying you
shots and things like that
but i actually had the honor of being in
howard w koch's office at paramount uh
your sweet dad and we all of the winners
were in his office and it was a
momentous moment and he looked at all of
us and said look i just want you to know
i'm not hiring any of you
and that's david me today
please close the curtain please
please that's so upsetting
well that was uh long enough back then
the film entries were actually accepted
on film and it was 16 millimeter it was
long enough ago that kodak was our
sponsor and assured us that together we
all had a future in the film business
now they can't even support the circus
at hollywood and highland
that would be kodak because they pulled
out
of that theater
thank you thank you hawk
i'll be thank you individually for
responding winning a student academy
award is a huge notch in your headboard
that's what it says
it just says it there and that's what i
i always show it to
don't listen to this funny um
it's i show it to the ladies i go look
my student academy award it's it's the
first thing i show to a woman
and they find it very appealing usually
because they're students and um
that's uh so it's on there i had no
choice but to say it
and i keep it on a very low shelf in
case they're with circuit of soleil but
um but that is not why i am here tonight
i am here tonight because they paid me
fifty thousand dollars
and i'm making a film with it um
i am here because this is uh this is
honestly a a true honor and again
i did want to mention that my nephew now
is 42 years old and he is very
successful
and doing really well and and lives in
la and he needs a woman
again this year the filmmakers all of
you know that you have won the national
awards but we are going to reveal them
to them and to you the gold silver and
bronze medal award winners in each
category here on our stage tonight
whatever the outcome though i want to
offer my sincere congratulations to all
of tonight's winning filmmakers the
members of the academy have seen your
films i've seen your films and they feel
you're all off to a great start which
you truly are and they want you to keep
up the great work please give everybody
a round of applause